une poignée de mains pour sceller
l'union entre deux hommes et de liste
après des mois de dissension Alain ou
pair et Emmanuel Bichot se sont donc
entendus après une semaine de
négociation dans le contrat d'union
Alain houpère garder évidemment la tête
de lys Emmanuel Bichot prendra lui la
septième place et 6 de ses partisans
l'accompagneront quant au programme ils
vont fusionner cet accord c'est
peut-être pas un accord parfait mais en
tout cas il répond à deux conditions
essentielles que nous avions fixées qui
était que mon équipe soit représentée et
nous serons effectivement présents avec
trois représentants du collectif agir
pour Dijon dans les 10 premières places
et puis quelques représentants dans le
dans la suite de la liste et puis
deuxièmement que nous puissions
fusionner les programmes après avoir
déjà réalisé plusieurs ententes en
confiant la troisième place à
bourguignan et la cinquième à l'UDI
Alain houpère pourra donc présenter une
liste UMP unifiée le sénateur voit dans
cette fusion un nouvel élan pour sa
campagne avec désormais un seul
adversaire François rebsamé aujourd'hui
c'est l'union d'une droite rassemblée
pour un seul objectif
conquérir la ville de Dijon notre
adversaire c'est François Rebsamen le
maire sortant de Dijon et aujourd'hui
c'est un jour important puisque c'est le
jour du dernier conseil municipal de la
majorité sortante mais moi je vous donne
rendez-vous le vendredi au lendemain du
deuxième tour justement pour voir une
nouvelle majorité derrière mon
leadership reste toutefois quelques
détails à finaliser la liste complète
n'est pas encore établie tout comme le
programme commun des réunions entre les
deux camps auront lieu dans les
prochains jours